9e allocutions présidentielles depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire emmanuel
macron s'est exprimé ce soir devant les
français avec une première partie
consacrée aux copies 19 le président de
la république a notamment insisté sur
l'importance de la vaccination et
demande aux français d'être responsable
et solidaire les détails avec notre
reporter n'a déjà des razak
c'est la neuvième fois depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire que le président
de la république s'adresse aux français
lors d'une allocution télévisée
allocution de 27 minutes au cours de
laquelle emmanuel macron s'est exprimé
avec une voix assez inhabituelle une
voix assez grave peut-être dû un mal de
gorge quoi qu'il en soit le chef de
l'état a appelé à l'esprit de
responsabilité les six millions de
français éligibles qui n'ont pas encore
été vaccinés il a déclaré que pour être
libres dans un pays comme la france il
fallait être responsable et solidaire
emmanuel macron qui a conditionné la
validation du pass sanitaires à une
troisième dose de vaccin pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans une
campagne a été lancée depuis la fin de
l'été pour tous les plus de 65 ans et
les plus fragiles il nous faut
aujourd'hui l'accélérer
si vous avez été vaccinées il ya plus de
six mois
je vous appelle à vous protéger en
prenant rendez vous dès maintenant
auprès d'un centre de vaccination de
votre médecin ou de votre pharmacien il
est possible de faire ce rappel en même
temps que le vaccin contre la grippe à
partir du 15 décembre
il vous faudra justifier d'un rappel
pour prolonger la validité de votre pass
sanitaires pour vivre normalement il
faut être vaccinés avoir un passé
sanitaires et continuer à appliquer les
gestes barrière a fait savoir le
président de la république emmanuel
macron écarté en tout cas pour l'heure
la vaccination des enfants de moins de
12 ans alors outre l épidémie et
emmanuel macron a évoqué ses projets
pour la fin de son quinquennat alors il
faut dire que lors de cette allocution
télévisée le chef de l'état apparu en
campagne présidentielle même s'il ne
sait pas or à présenter candidat à sa
propre réélection